what is stress according to psychology
stress is a feeling of emotional or
physical strain and pressure stress can
be positive or negative small amount of
positive stress is beneficial and
healthy it helps in improving
performance motivation and adaptation
negative stress is a big box full of
problems it decreases performance
demotivates individual and leads to
mental and physical problems dr. hans
lai founder of the stress theory
according to him stress can be perceived
by a person in two forms which he called
as negative stress distress and the
positive stress known as you stress the
simplest way to understand what you
stress and distress mean is by looking
back at the exam times just a few days
before the exam you feel stressed and
under pressure some of us are able to
use that feeling positively and it
becomes a motivation to study harder and
perform better and that feeling becomes
ultimately useful this is you stress
while the rest of us respond very poorly
to the situation and feel anxious you
feel all those emotions in your head you
feel dizzy nauseated even gets sick
during this period you may have studied
well for the exams but the pressure and
stress gets on your nerves and you
perform very less than your potential
this is distress now that we have
understood what the term stress means
let's look at what happens when you are
stressed
during the times of stress the
hypothalamus a collection of nuclei that
connects the brain and the endocrine
system signals a pituitary gland to
produce a hormone which in turn signals
adrenal glands located above the kidneys
to increase the production of cortisol
this is extremely useful in short-term
scenarios that is why cortisol is known
as the stress hormone in humans one of
the systems that responds to challenging
circumstances or stress is the immune
system broadly the immune system
comprises of cells proteins
organs and tissues that work together to
provide protection against bodily
diseases during acute stress that lasts
for a matter of minutes or ours the
immune system mobilizes the cells which
prepare the body for injury or infection
these immune cells under the influence
of cortisol fight off infections and the
body manages the stressful scenario in
this process pro-inflammatory cytokines
are also produced which are necessary
for eliminating pathogens and initiating
healing however this process of
inflammation has its own problems as it
leads to oxidative damage free radical
damage cellular deaths aging and
systemic tissue degeneration to prevent
this our body secretes cortisol it
provides the energy that is required to
deal with the challenge it's also a
potent anti-inflammatory that prevents
damage to the body's own cells
Kaiko Glasser and
scientists performed an experiment on
medical students to observe the effects
of exam time stress on immunity these
medical students were divided into two
groups
out of which 49 were males and 26 were
females the team of scientists took
blood samples from both the groups
before the exam which was a relatively
low stress time and after the exam which
was a high stress time the activity of
lymphocytes was checked in the blood
samples of both the groups before and
after the exam and the researchers found
that immune responses were weak in the
students after the exam and also
influence who are experiencing stressful
life events and psychiatric symptoms
such as depression or anxiety what does
this immune system dysfunction do to the
stress lead to your tendency and
frequency of falling sick increases
exponentially also if you are already
having an illness your symptoms might
get progressively severe sustained
cortisol activity during stress is
associated with an increase in
gastrointestinal symptoms which explains
the stomachaches and frequent visits to
the washrooms high level of information
promoting cytokines resulting from
stress have recently been implicated in
the etiology of psychiatric disorders
chronic stress has been shown to enhance
risk for developing autoimmune diseases
because of constant immune system
dysfunction also there is bone and
muscle breakdown fatigue depression pain
and memory impairments all of us are
aware of the global pandemic that we are
facing in this world today and the only
thing that can protect us from this
global pandemic is our own immunity here
is a video series on the topic of how to
boost your immunity as well as the
structure and function of our immune
system all links are in the description
below thank you so much for watching see
you in the next video